ce n'est pas un jour d'école pourtant
ces élèves du primaire sont en classe au
cégep de rosemont et ils sont très
concentrés
ils y sont pour faire leurs devoirs de
français de mathématiques et aussi pour
passer du temps avec leur mentor c'est
le cas de caroline à 10 ans c'est l'fun
s'est amusé
et on fait beaucoup de choses aussi
l'initiative s'appelle l'école des
grands c'est un programme parascolaire
de mentorat ou des étudiants du
collégial offre de l'aide aux devoirs
aux enfants issus de milieux défavorisés
vont danser les écoles les plus
défavorisés au québec de l'oeil à des
élèves avec des moyens dans 50 70% et
minérales aux primaires qui viennent au
cégep du quartier pas recevoir de l'aide
aux devoirs en français et en maths
comme ici pour les banques alimentaires
sont des collégiens bénévoles du cégep
issus de tous les programmes de tous les
profils score pour les mentors du groupe
l'appui apporté à ses enfants dépassent
largement le contexte académique et au
boulot en sait quelque chose j'ai
toujours eu la réputation d'être parmi
les pires de la classe qui avait les
pires notes il a suffit seulement de une
seule personne un seul professeur qui
m'a dit
que j'étais une personne intelligente
qui
pouvait avoir quelques caves est la
valeur
l'initiative semble avoir des résultats
concrets une amélioration des résultats
scolaires a été observée les élèves
qu'on verse pas les que les grands
augmentent leurs notes de l'art français
en mathématiques et en sciences selon
cette professeur universitaire certaines
conditions doivent être réunies pour que
ce type de programme favorise réellement
la réussite scolaire créer un climat de
confiance être bienveillant tout ça mais
aussi être capable de recentrer sur la
tâche parce que être capable d'avoir un
but précis de séances de tutorat en
séances de tutorat ça aussi c'est
important le programme parascolaire
défaire actuellement cinq écoles
primaires de montréal et de trois
rivières et si mélissa françois radio
canada montréal